Oh
know I heard a lot about Jose's story,
which reminds me a lot in my story.
I just want to be an encouragement to him
today. I get to know him a little bit.
Spent some time with him.
Hang out.
Yeah,
it seems
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
it was cover.
I love her.
How was 13 when I had my first drink,
it was at a party.
I was always a shy kid and it gave
me the courage to actually, you know,
talk to girls.
I liked that confidence and so I
wanted him more of it and more of it.
That's when I started
getting hooked on to it.
When I think about him, I get emotional
because right outside his door,
homelessness,
drugs in his face offer to him.
They see him on the corner.
I've seen him, you know,
make the wrong choices.
December 8th,
2010 it started off as a normal day.
You went to a party. We brought
alcohol. They brought, we'd never had,
I've mixed drugs with alcohol,
but at the moment like I didn't care
when got drunk, I'm not spelled.
And when the party ended,
I remember walking outside.
As soon as I opened the door,
everything slowed down.
Every time I close my eyes,
I saw a bright light.
I was slowly given into it.
The paramedics rushed then.
Okay.
And I saw my mom for the first time.
It seemed as if she saw her son dead.
Well,
my heart just pretty much shut to pieces.
So he's framing 40 [inaudible] not always
you on business. Tell me more or less the,
is it too narrow? They knew
me. Smile. Okay. Synthetic
from my action,
I
could have lost everything.
Oh my mom must be important.
Right. There was when it hit me
that I was going the wrong way.
So I knew it was a, for nine years
now as a teacher and a coach,
all hate dot. Bob was,
basketball is stuck in my life.
Every time I stepped on the court,
like my mind would just go blank now.
Just focus on what was ahead of me,
drinking or smoking or whatever it was.
I didn't need all that. I just
needed a ball and a hoop anyway.
And you know, I went, in many cases
I would consider myself an underdog.
I'm not a big guy. I don't bring
a big presence to the court sound.
My Room wasn't an MBA. The people, they,
when you take the first class that
you don't expect much from them,
such as of German land
to become the first one of the
first class to come from Palo Alto.
Like what did it take for him to actually
overcome all the obstacles that he
went through?
Yeah. When things are rough, I
like Romans five, three to five.
It's about
how through your suffering,
like the end goal is joy.
Yeah.
I was ready to quit many times.
The toughest obstacle was probably finding
someone that would give me a chance
and uh,
and there are people who
had to call me and be like,
you're going to show up tomorrow
and you're going to go to practice.
You're not going to quit.
Yeah,
no.
I heard a lot about Jose's story.
I just want to be an encouragement to him
today. I get to know him a little bit,
spend some time with him,
hang out.
He's down there.
He thinks he's just doing drills for
the camera and it's all going to try to
surprise him. Yeah, we'll see how it goes.
What was it
like trying not to jump around and,
you know, seemed like a little kid,
but I wanted to, but you nationally
to keep my cool. It's hard
to take in right now. I was
not expecting this, you know,
seeing you play and then now
I get to meet you in person.
If it's mind blowing.
We're all
in. You got to pay. You want to
Oh, oh, play me one on one? Yeah.
Okay. You going to get
right to it then, Huh? Yeah,
because he's been through
what he's been through.
He has a solid foundation and understands
a lot more than a typical
18 year old night.
You can hear it in his voice so you can
see it. You can see it in his smile.
And he talks a lot about, um, his joy.
The neat thing about it is if he
didn't go through, you know, the,
the addiction and, and, and
the drugs and the alcohol,
I think his perception or understanding
of joy would be different.
Okay.
I've caused my parents so much pain
and I caused myself a lot of pain.
I had to suffer, but you know,
I still have faith in God.
I still pray every night before I go
to bed because that night I could have
easily gone round over in the streets,
but someone was looking over
me that night, you know,
you know, suffering, um, can look like
a lot of different things, but uh,
everything always happens for a reason.
Okay.
I still get haunted by that day. You
know, I can still hear my mom cry,
but that motivates me to keep going and
finishing strong and going to college
and making them proud
just seem pretty similar. The two sales
look, assess it is not who you are. Yes.
Yep.
Hey,
thanks all for checking out Jose Story.
Really appreciate Jeremy Lin for
coming out and thanks to Julie Project.
You know, they're doing a great job
of telling the story at all you guys.
So hopefully you guys check it out.
Okay.